le tenue mi alimentaire plusieurs en
rêvent mais est-ce qu'on a les moyens
d'y parvenir
j'en discute avec pascal thériault
agronome économiste enseignant et
directeur à l'université mcgill
[Musique]
pascal depuis un an on nous dit on nous
parle et on nous convainquent
l'autonomie alimentaire chez nous c'est
possible mais est-ce que c'est utopique
où on peut vraiment y croire
la pleine autonomie alimentaire c'est un
peu un voeu pieux sans doute on a appris
comme consommateurs apprécient tout ce
qu'on pouvait découvrir dans nos
épiceries et justement on est arrivé
dans une situation où est ce que on
s'était habitué à voir cet exotisme
alimentaire et et à vouloir et pouvoir
manger un peu ce qu'on veut donc de
passer que du jour au lendemain on
tomberait dans une pleine autonomie
alimentaire et qu'on sait qu'ils
finiraient nos banane normal nos avocats
je pense que ce serait pas réaliste de
dire que ça va nous l'entente du coq
sixièmement les gens sont prêts à faire
des sacrifices quand même sont prêts à
changer leurs habitudes en ce moment si
vous n'avez pas l'impression qu'on
pourrait prendre un petit virage ou
moins mais il y avait un frère ce que
j'ai déjà commencé de 2 le consommateur
est de plus en plus conscientisés à la
réalité de l'agriculture locale et aux
bienfaits d'acheter de la nourriture
produite localement ou transformés
localement la part des milieux une chose
de positif dans cette pandémie et que ça
le multiplier cet effet là je sais que
c'est aussi hyper complexe qu'on n'aura
pas le temps d'expliquer mais on se dit
pourquoi le parc on exporte à plein
conteneurs et les fruits de mer et
poissons qui partent soit pour qu'on
gagne pas cette richesse mais ici le
canada est un grand exportateur
agroalimentaire donc on est un espèce de
dualité agroalimentaire parce que d'un
côté on a nos productions sous gestion
de l'offre et de l'autre on aime toutes
ces denrées agroalimentaires comparé des
grains compères du parc qu'on va
exporter
donc c'est très difficile d'avoir en
place des mesures protectionnistes
premièrement parce que ces deux
compétences fédérales de notre
compétence provinciale donc qu'est-ce
qui reste pour nous consommateurs
québécois il reste une volonté du
gouvernement de peut-être encourager les
epci davantage
bien étiquetés à bien mettre en valeur
les produits du québec plutôt que
d'inciter donner des subventions pour
qu'il y ait de la production qu'ils
soient exportés
si on prenait cet argent à l'ope qu'on
réduise est le prix du panier d'épicerie
on n'aurait pas le droit de faire ça
c'est quoi cette des grands entente
politique internationale qui nous
empêche de faire sont dans des granges à
hors jeu de commerciaux mondiaux
c'est toujours le prix qui va prévaloir
quand on parle d'aliments tous les coups
qui sont reliées à la production en tant
que tel souvent sont laissés dans le
pays d'origine donc importer un aliment
mais il ne nous reste que l'aliment et
le prix quand tu arrives ici tout ce qui
était pollution tout ce qui était main
d'oeuvre peut-être même soupe et y est
resté dans l'autre pays
donc quand le consommateur achète un
produit au québec ben il s'assure que le
produit est produit selon nos règles
environnementales à nous et que nos
producteurs sont rémunérés de façon
adéquate
ici au québec donc il faudrait peut-être
effectivement dans les ententes
commerciales futures qu'on se marche un
peu seul sur le côté globale du prix de
l'aliment et non pas juste sur le prix
final de cet animal qu'est ce qu'il en
coûte pour produire et qu'est-ce qu'on
laisse dans les autres pays
quand on importe des aliments moins cher
ici encourager nos producteurs c'est
encourager d une multitude de petites
pme puis je pense que comme citoyen si
on est pour penser d'eux dans une
optique d'autonomie alimentaire
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut garder
aussi on dit qu'on mangera à peu près
30% de ce qui produit chez nous després
mousson pourrait augmenter sa à combiers
un court terme n'ont pas l'air convaincu
au niveau des fruits et légumes der sar
est ce qu'on est un pays nordique
on y limiter un peu dans notre capacité
de produire toute l'année donc on peut
faire des efforts pour manger plus de
saison quand c'est l'hiver mais sont si
bien que par deux saisons autrefois
s'impliquer se restreindre aux pommes de
terre oignons navets carottes
beaucoup de consommateurs sont prêts à
faire ce sacrifice l'a donc est-ce qu'on
peut manger plus local oui c'est de
faire un effort quand c'est le temps de
manger les fruits et légumes de saison
entre autres pour ce qui est de la
viande bien évidemment qu'on peut
travailler avec nos transformateurs on
peut travailler à
nos épiciers pour s'assurer que
davantage de produits du québec qui
rentrent
on pourrait pas être autosuffisant le
canada peut-être pas à 100% mais 90%
le canada est quand même autour
suffisamment dans une certaine mesure
parce qu'effectivement bon le beurre de
l'alberta reste au canada quand même
puis on a quand même des fruits et
légumes de l'ontario de la
colombie-britannique qui vont rentrer au
québec mais de façon traditionnelle et
naturel
on a quand même une chaîne
d'approvisionnement par exemple avec la
californie ou avec la floride qui est là
depuis des années qui est efficace que
la chaîne logistique est bien rodée puis
quand on sait qu'on n'était pas dans la
voir pour combler toutes ces périodes de
l'année au québec où est ce que ces
mêmes canadiens ou est ce qu'on n'est
pas capable de produire de façon
économiquement efficace on ne peut pas
se dire que dans dix ans on pourrait
avoir une grande variété même de fruits
on peut passer à court terme que on
pourrait augmenter grandement notre
autonomie alimentaire
on a vu dans les dernières années une
hausse des dons d'entreprise agricole
puis cette hausse risque de continuer
dans au moins pour les prochaines années
à venir
donc il ya un engouement pour les
producteurs de sept ans sa production
agricole il d'un maxi un logo pour les
producteurs c'est parce qu'un
consommateur qui est prêt à faire cet
achat la donc est ce que nous sommes
prêts à faire davantage de celle au cou
moi je crois que oui le gouvernement
avant les fêtes demande aux québécois
d'augmenter leur part du panier
d'épicerie de 12 ans aux femmes
sahraouies et qui est un exercice
extraordinaire parce que ça nous permet
de prendre le temps de découvrir des
produits qui vont rentrer tranquillement
dans nos habitudes d'achat
si vous avez une baguette magique si on
se parlait dans un an dans deux ans ce
serait quoi prétend beau rêve collectif
selon vous on a commencé à le voir du
côté des epci moi ce serait qu'il soit
très clairement identifié ce produit
vient dit
je pense que ça ne devrait pas être en
reste ça devrait être une réalité merci
beaucoup